mein lena
das ist wirklich liebt von deiner mutter
des jungen starthilfe gegeben hat ist
wirklich toll ja manchmal hat es doch
vorteile das soll eine mutter hat von
autos hätte ich finde jeder taxifahrer
sollte eine solche mutter los geht ist
das nicht alleine geschafft
du bist doch ein mann mit erfahrung
natürlich aber ich meine frauen und
technik
hey was ist los mit euch nicht schlapp
machen
ich will diesen berg sowieso nicht hoch
ich dachte wir fahren in die stadt jedes
system drachenfels von oben bietet sich
einem eine wunderschöne aussicht
der rhein bonn königswinter wenn man
diese richtung schaut kann man sogar den
kölner dom sehen aber der weg ist so
anstrengend
weißt du was wir können mit der bahnhof
waren da ist man auch viel schneller
oben
dann sind wir auch schneller wieder
unten tolle idee sag mal wie ist das
eigentlich mit ihr und carla
auseinandergegangen
das ist eine lange geschichte aber es
ist gut dass es vorbei ist und du rennst
immer noch diesen bällen hinterher im
moment renne ich nur einen steilen weg
hoch wo ist denn eigentlich diese bahn
also ich finde architektur wirklich
total spannend vielleicht wäre das ja
auch was für mich wie bist du denn drauf
gekommen bist zu studieren ich mag den
technischen aspekt und dass du da etwas
gestalten kannst hier nicht toll
mein vater ist übrigens überhaupt nicht
glücklich gewesen mit meiner studienwahl
dass die perser so stolz auf unsere
architektur sind mein vater findet auch
gar nichts gut egal was ich mache
ihm wäre es wohl am liebsten wenn ich
heirate und liebe kinder kriege